good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2001
object class ketter
special containment procedures no means
of containment or prevention of scp-2001
is currently available to the foundation
in lieu of this several alternative
procedures have been established
gamma type individuals and beta type
individuals not affiliated
with nasa or any other space-related
organization
should be monitored and detained if
necessary individuals employed or
affiliated with space-related
organizations
who show signs of gamma or beta-type
infection
should be removed from service and
administered amnestics
effective october 21st 2000 all
individuals afflicted with alpha-type
symptoms should be detained in wing
of sector under no circumstances should
alpha-type individuals be allowed access
to
any astronomical or space-faring
equipment mandatory scp-2001 screening
is in effect
for all foundation staff addendum
april 22nd 1990
in light of incident 2001 1990
a all foundation employees showing
symptoms of scp-2001 are to be removed
from service immediately
see incident report 2001
a level four clearance or higher
description scp-2001 is an anomalous
series of neural oscillations
that occur during three of the four
stages of human sleep
during one of these three stages the
amygdala spontaneously enters a state of
heightened activity for a period of 10
to 15 minutes
awakening the subject during this period
appears to immediately switch the
response
of the individual to alpha type
regardless of the sleep stage in which
scp-2001 activity occurs
at the conclusion of scp-2001's active
state
the subject is conditioned to one of
three responses
designated alpha beta and gamma
depending on the sleep stage in which
scp-2001
occurred scp-2001 appears to show
no increased presence in individuals of
any race
creed or gender no genetic abnormalities
have been associated with scp-2001
spectrographic analysis of scp-2001
suggests that its presence may not be
intra-neural
rather that it may originate from an
outside source of particular node is the
fact that scp-2001
particularly the alpha strain has
recently begun affecting a
proportionally large population of
astronomers
astronauts and individuals who otherwise
deal with space
individuals who already possess a
critical attitude towards space
exploration generally exhibit no
anomalous effects from scp-2001 activity
there appear to be three types of
responses to scp-2001 infection
scp-2001 has not been documented to
occur
in the first stage of nrem sleep
gamma subjects who experience scp-2001
during the second stage of any rm
non-rapid eye movement sleep are
designated gamma-type
individuals gamma-type individuals are
almost indistinguishable from the
ordinary population
say from a disparaging attitude towards
the topic of space travel
gamma-type individuals show an active
aversion to discussing space or space
exploration
in conversations and will avoid any and
all organizations pertaining to the
study and development of human space
exploration
it is estimated that percent of the
population is currently affected by
gamma-type symptoms
of scp-2001 beta
subjects who experience scp-2001 during
the third stage of nerm sleep
are designated beta type individuals
beta type individuals are characterized
by
a distinct opposition to space
exploration beta type individuals will
denounce the importance and safety of
space travel
in conversations citing it as extremely
dangerous
or fruitless also common among beta type
individuals is the tendency to construct
elaborate conspiracy theories
regarding humans in space an estimated
percent of popular space-related
conspiracies
are directly linked to one or more beta
type carriers
including of node is the fact that the
aforementioned individual had never had
contact with the scp foundation
or any of its affiliates alpha
the presence of scp-2001 during any
stage of rem
sleep produces an alpha-type individual
alpha-type individuals actively attempt
to stop or sabotage
all forms of space travel individuals
displaying symptoms of alpha-type
infection will attempt to harm or
otherwise
interfere with individuals centers and
activities that
pertain to space research or travel an
alpha positive foundation researcher was
directly responsible
for incident 2001 1990
a level 4 clearance or higher document
2001
1 incident report 2001
199 a level 4 clearance required
deploying security mimetic now
date april 22nd 1990
location foundation outpost 12 within
nasa command
coordinates note junior researcher
was in perfect mental health at the time
of the incident no
he was not insane no he was not under
any form of psychic control
he was an alpha type carrier of scp-2001
and that is all doctor the following
takes place during the launch of scps
a manned foundation shuttle tasked with
the investigation of scp
a crew of foundation supervisors were on
hand to ensure
safe takeoff and report any anomalous
activity
junior researchers was tasked with the
observation of status readings
12 37 pm head researcher reports
successful preparation for liftoff
of scps 12 37 pm
junior researcher reported to become
extremely agitated
12 38 pm scps
achieves liftoff 12 38 pm researcher
begins yelling unintelligibly to nearby
staff
12 38 pm junior researcher produces
unknown artifact
resembling control pad now classified as
scp
12 38 pm researcher begins to operate
unknown artifact scps
reports several system failures 12 39
pm unknown artifact is confiscated by dr
scps reports total loss of power
12 39 pm communications with scps
6 hull of scps begins to break down
the resulting explosion was explained to
onlookers and the press
has a gps satellite that had suffered a
fuel leak during launch
no foundation witnesses were
administered amnestics
following the above events and
posthumous diagnosis of junior
researchers
with scp-2001 containment procedures
were altered to provide stricter
containment of scp-2001
alpha carriers full documentation
including termination report
can be found at document scp-2001-9
excerpt from journal of junior
researchers
level 4 clearance required security
memetic deployed
april 21st 1990
i wish to state first that my mind and
body are perfectly
sound i am prepared to submit myself to
any and all tests to prove that i'm
clean
i have the answer to scp-2001
just yesterday during an interview with
an alpha infected d-class
i was asked a question that stopped my
mind for a minute the woman i was
interviewing asked me if i knew the
foundation was right
i said no i wasn't sure then she asked
me what if we were right
i could only assume that by we she meant
2001
carriers i said nothing for a while and
then she spoke
she told me of a dream she'd had a while
ago she said that something
talked to her told her about how
dangerous outer space was
it showed her the beasts that roamed the
void between the stars
about the fractal beings that absorbed
the very fabric of reality
about the that were keeping in that god
forsaken door
and she was scared she told me that at
the end of the dream
as she woke up it told her what it was
it's all of space space fears for us
we're living breathing life forms and
space loves us
and cherishes us she asked me if i had
any idea what the chances of intelligent
life forming on another planet are
and then she told me a number that took
a minute and a half to recite
by this point i couldn't speak i started
thinking about the demographics of
infection about the symptoms about
and suddenly it all made sense some of
the things she said stuck in my brain
and they all added up to the same thing
are in grave danger if we go out there
we can't go out there
we can't go out there we can't
there's a reason behind scp-2001 and
it's nowhere near as terrifying as all
my colleagues think
space wants to protect us there are
things out there that would wipe
humanity clean off this plane of
existence
and we're too precious to our mother to
our host
to the universe we live in for her to
allow that to happen
what i'm gonna do tomorrow is not a
result of infection it's
not a result of madness it's not a
result of anything other than purist
knowledge
you see i found out the truth and it's
more beautiful than i ever could have
dreamed
addendum april 30th 1990
research into potential memetic
qualities of scp-2001
is currently ongoing transcriptive email
from
head of scp-2001 research team to site
director
october 21st 2000 level 4
clearance required security memetic
deployed
the research team and i have just made a
rather unsettling discovery regarding
scp-2001
our suspicions were peaked when we found
journal
first the writing leading up to the day
of the incident was entirely different
in tone than the rest of the journal
he rants and raves about space for pages
and pages
it's as if he just spewed his brain onto
the page second it wasn't something he
would ever do
end the lives of five foundation
astronauts the way he did
that's something we neglected to mention
about 2001's alpha stream
that individuals seeking to interfere
with manned space travel will not
undertake actions
outside their moral reasoning this meant
that the alpha strain of scp-2001 was
safer than it seemed
or so we thought see we proved beyond
the shadow of a doubt that
did have scp-2001 all the symptoms he
displayed were completely on target for
the alpha string with the exception of
his final actions
so we researched it more specifically we
researched the d-class that he talked to
on the day before the crash
we sent subjects into her cell and asked
her to talk to them
she said just about the same thing to
most people with a couple of exceptions
when she talked to certain subjects she
would pepper rants with a couple of
distinct phrases and what we discovered
was that the individuals who responded
to these phrases
began to behave in a similar manner to
on the day of the crash
by now i'm sure you can deduce what we
learned from these findings
it appears there is some sort of fourth
strain
one that functions differently from any
of the three we have encountered before
we call it alpha prime it is a mimetic
variant propagated by certain
individuals afflicted with
the alpha strain through the use of
several trigger phrases
if a listener responds to those phrases
the symptoms of alpha prime begins to
develop
though not much more potent than the
regular alpha strain in terms of the
carrier's attitude
towards space exploration it does have
the additional effect of
overriding the moral code of its hosts
we don't know exactly to what lengths an
alpha prime carrying subject would go to
prevent us from engaging in manned space
travel
perhaps therein lies the most worrying
element of this newfound strain
we know next to nothing about it it is
the opinion of myself and many members
of the research team that this
information should be kept separate from
the official scp-2001
documentation including the findings
about the moral restrictions of the
standard alpha string
we don't know how many individuals have
succumbed to the words of their
alpha-inflicted colleagues
and we don't want a mass outbreak of
paranoia and fear among foundation
personnel
if word spreads about a
sociopathy-inducing memetic variant of
2001
we have no idea what could happen within
our ranks
quite frankly we don't want to find out
standard scp-2001 checks are still in
order for all sites
tell the mobile task forces to keep
rounding up the alpha strains and
sending them to me
after all we've got the counter names to
develop
we secure we contain we protect
level 4 research head
this concludes today's lecture thank you
all for listening
if indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
noises conquest zargaram
professor puffer the morrigan
retalias karim el hashmuy
big onion bean sayo dio demnatas
revenant brian sanchez
matthew gilmore eric corbeage
kauai fire keeper longinus
carcass death aqua king madding
james saba nj vojak
and oblong doucheboy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you